you buy yourself a four gigabyte flash
memory you actually probably got a six
gigabyte of flash memory when you
manufacture them the silicon process
will lead to certain of this transistors
just not working and of course we can
remap those blocks and just not use them
so we map out some of the drives and we
have a list of bad blocks but we also
have a bit of overhead because that
allows us to say yes you have a 4
gigabyte drive we can fill it up if
someone has a disk that's at capacity
and they think they're over writing the
same file they don't want the
performance to suddenly drop to the
arrays performance so there's usually a
bit more memory on there than you think
so we can take a burst of writes and of
course the microcontroller needs to be
able to see all of that and it does all
this mapping and it's not uncommon that
for there to be a hidden command
sequence to the microcontroller that it
recognizes for debug purposes because in
the factory you want to test it so
sometimes you can get a test interfaces
of these microcontrollers and read the
whole contents of the memory quite
easily or the other thing is you go in
and you physically extract the memory
and you put it in another device that
that can actually do that but you know
debugging test modes for these little
microcontrollers there's sort of
features that are not widely advertised
in the usual guides for these devices
but I'm sure if you went to a
manufacturer and ask them nicely and
especially if you turn up with a warrant
you may we'll find that you'd get that
information aside to access them